kelly good morning how are we doing i'm
good how are you doing
i am doing to quote the great dave
ramsey better than i deserve
how can i help um so i've struggled with
anxiety for a while
um but haven't needed medication in
years i've recently started taking meds
again
to help with the increased anxiety of
2020
and i'm struggling with feelings of
failure and brokenness i'm not quite
sure how to navigate that
so you say you haven't taken medication
in a while when did you last take
medication
about 10 years ago tell me about the
circumstances surrounding that
um we were my husband and i um at the
time we were engaged
and moved to florida away from
family and friends and were planning a
wedding at the time too so there was a
lot of stress going on
and saw a doctor and
they thought it was a good idea since i
had a history of depression
um as well that medication would be
the best thing for me to be on to get
through
all of the stressors and so how long did
you take
medication for just to get you through
that season um yeah
i think it ended up being about a year
okay and then what are the things you
did to help heal
during that time in addition to
medication
um i guess i kept busy with you know
with my job at the time
socializing with friends getting out of
the house
going on you know weekend trips with my
husband
and um just different things to keep my
mind off of
what might be going on that wasn't so
great in my life
so fast forward 10 years to right now
what what finally pushed you over the
edge and said i need to go see a doctor
again
um i mean i know we're all
in the same position with the pandemic
and um hold on hold on people are
i don't want you to compare your
situation to others
i want you just to tell your story
because your story by itself has value
and i know other people's got it worse i
got that i want you to tell me what
what happened in your life that made you
one day open your eyes and say i gotta
go see somebody
um i i try not to watch the news
but um i have continued to go to the gym
to exercise throughout everything
and there are screens everywhere there
so you see
it's getting worse stay home don't go
anywhere don't see family for
thanksgiving
and um it was probably about two weeks
ago that
i hit rock bottom and um but what what
besides
what besides the news something else
um my my mom i love her
um she recently retired i get calls
every day from her
asking how are cases down where you are
are you guys okay
what you know what's going on so that
kind of triggers the
oh my gosh like this is this is getting
bad this is crazy
and um that just
you know i see her name pop up on my
caller id
and it just freaks me out because i know
we're about to talk about stuff that
gets my anxiety going
so back up a little bit do you have a
good relationship with your mom
um kind of it's not great
okay so the answer to that question is
no i can answer that for you because
you're a good human being and you're
gonna say kind of so
i appreciate that about you um walk me
back to when you're a teenager
how did you and your mom get along
not great um what is not great
um i wasn't really given a whole lot of
choices in
how my life was going at the time i was
required to do these certain lessons or
required to take these courses in school
so i didn't really feel like i had a lot
of flexibility or freedom or
voice in um you know day-to-day choices
it was kind of
picked for me what about your dad how'd
you get along with your old man
um growing up as a teenager he and i
fought all the time but now
he is probably my favorite person in the
entire world
that's awesome he's meant more to me as
i've become a parent
i have a lot of respect for him and tell
me about your kids
i have one little boy he just turned
seven
we would have loved to have more but
he's he's
the one we were given and um i'm so
proud of him he's amazing
okay so i'm gonna answer your question
in a bigger funnel than the one you
initially called me about but i will get
to your question directly
okay okay so a couple of things to note
number one anxiety and depression are on
the same trend line
they are not distinct things like a
broken ankle and cancer are
okay so they usually work in tandem
together
and one leads to the other one or one
will push you towards feelings of
one or the other okay so i don't want
you to think that you've got
all of these quote unquote things your
body has a particular way of taking care
of you
and it will usually start with an alarm
system
and it will usually start with another
alarm and then another one and it will
get louder and louder until
one of the safest most comfortable ways
of shutting those alarms off
is turning the lights off and getting
under the covers and watching netflix
or drinking or fill in the blank with
any number of numbing behaviors working
120 hours a week
the second thing is and you've probably
heard me say this 100 times i'm going to
say it a thousand times more
all anxiety is is an alarm system
and the alarms go off generally when
someone
is out of control they don't have
control over their situation
when they are disconnected or in their
body
immediate is fearful of not being safe
and so when you back me up to your life
situations
you grew up in a house where you had no
control
people didn't care what you had to say
about things they dictated to you the
way you were gonna be and what you were
going to do
then you entered a season where you
packed up and left
everyone and everything you know to a
new adventure
where you were totally disconnected you
had little to no control you were
signing up and your husband may be
incredible he may be the greatest guy
ever
but you are still hitching your wagon to
somebody else right that's a known
an unknown entity how's this thing going
to work starting a new job
you have a history of depression and
then finally your alarms get so loud
that you go see a doctor which i'm proud
of you for going good for you
and then we reach this new place where
you've got this new moment in history
and it's not a new moment but it's new
for us
we're literally we're entering we're
leaving a or we're still in the middle
of it
um we're a couple days out from
christmas and people are still throwing
crayons at each other about the election
but you realize we don't control much
anything when it comes to democracy i
get my vote and that's it
i control very little when it comes to a
pandemic sweeping through a control very
little when it comes to the economy and
who's telling me i can work and can't
work
and then you throw on top of that
infertility challenges that you've
experienced for years
which then lead to identity questions
who am i why isn't my body working for
me
why can't i be the fill in the blank my
husband's identity is included in this
and suddenly your alarms are ringing off
the hook right
and so here's why i'm telling you these
things number one
i've experienced everything i've just
told you about
except i experienced infertility on the
other side of that
i've been crippled by anxiety myself
where my alarms are just
yelling and yelling and yelling and it's
almost
always environmental in nature it's
almost always about our ecosystem what
is the world we've created for ourselves
and what is the world we're inheriting
right what is the world we are just
simply
in and i'm telling you that because i
don't want you to believe for one second
that you're broken
that your body's not working that it's
revolting
and that there's any sort of shame about
what's going on with you
okay okay
your body is working exactly how it was
designed to
and then you layer on top of it all of
the complexities
a mom who still loves hanging on to you
and controlling you and giving you
advice
and that's not because she's ugly or
mean or hateful
that's her way of showing you that she
loves you right
yes you've got that little boy i've got
a 10 year old and a
and an almost five-year-old and so you
and i are both
looking at this world our kids are going
to grow up in going what in the world
right and my alarms are going off too
okay so you did something brave and you
went to talk to a doctor
here's what anxiety medication will do
for you
it simply turns the alarms off
it shuts the alarms down it it
it it turns the nozzle down on those
things turns the knob down on those
things
and makes them not so loud anymore and
here's the important thing about taking
anxiety medication
it's only as good as the work you do
getting well when the alarms are off
right
and so what that's going to look like
for you is figuring out
boundaries with your mom maybe for the
first time
maybe it will be a conversation with her
where you say mom
you call every day and i love you i will
not talk about
the coveted numbers in my area anymore
i'm done with that conversation
it may mean that you sit with your
husband
and you say the words out loud that are
in your heart
about how many kids you wish you'd had
versus the beautiful extraordinary son
that you do have
and putting yourself putting yourself
out there being vulnerable to hearing
what your husband has to say about his
thoughts
and y'all may have never had that
conversation you may have but you may
haven't
all that to say is there are boundary
conversations there are intimacy
conversations and intimacy is just
letting your thoughts finally be heard
it may mean that you're going to go see
a counselor and learn how to
engage and be in deep relationships with
people that are close to you
how to create new relationships which is
a skill none of us have myself included
that we've got to learn how to do those
things
but there is no shame in going to see a
doctor and saying i need help turning
these alarms off for a season
so i can come up with some new skills
some new strategies some new moments
some new conversations some new
boundaries
they're going to help me be well moving
forward
is that fair yes
very much you are worth
an environment that supports and
sustains you
you're a good good mom kelly
and you're a good wife
and you're a good citizen
and while we're on this topic i let's
just have this conversation
people have asked me about it a lot i'll
probably end up doing an entire show on
this someday
but here's the conversations we need to
have about medication
over the past 40 years 50 years
and further back and everyone's going to
try to nitpick this thing so let's just
be
open and honest and exhale i'm going to
give a
50 000 foot overview of this we have
become
enamored obsessed addicted
with psychopharmaceutical psychotropic
medications
meds for mental health issues and this
stems from
a a narrative that's been
given to us from doctors from medical
researchers and
most importantly from pharmaceutical
companies
and it's a myth that your brain
chemistry
is broken just like some people are born
five foot eight and some people are born
six foot two
some people are born with low serotonin
levels
some people are born with wacky dopamine
levels
and by some people maybe 25 to
50 freaking percent of the population
are born with altered brain chemistry
and here's the thing it allows us to
pass the buck on relationships on life
circumstances on
trauma on tragedy on systemic issues
like
poverty and racism and sexism
and abusive relationships alas is pat
lets us pass the buck on all of that
and i go to the doctor and i say i can't
get these thoughts out of my head
and many doctors won't ask you what's
going on in your life
tell me about your childhood tell me
about your situation right now are you
safe they say yeah you may have altered
serotonin levels take this
and if you're just broken then you
didn't do anything wrong
your environment doesn't matter you
don't need to change anything
you just need to take your pills and
head on down the road right
we take so many psychotropic drugs as a
nation
that they are now lacing our drinking
water we peed them out in such mass
concentrations that they're in the water
that we drink
as one writer said we're awash in them
literally it's in our drinking water now
one in five u.s adults
i think it's one in four women are on
some sort of
psychotropic medication for anxiety for
depression fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and the numbers are continuing to
increase increase increase
and so to put that in perspective you
would think that
if we had stumbled on a quote unquote
cure
for an illness for a disease for a
dysfunctional part of the human body
with one in five one in four people
taking these medications
that the numbers would go down they
would level off yet they're
not they are skyrocketing
and contrary to what you probably
believe and understand about how
research works and how the research
companies work
this isn't conspiracy nonsense blah blah
this is truth okay this isn't me
becoming like an internet influencer and
exposing this is just
factual okay most antidepressant studies
are paid for by pharmaceutical companies
and what that means is they own
the positive results of those studies
and they own the negative results of
those studies
and there's an economic incentive to
open a drawer and put the negative
studies in the drawer and shut it
they write the reports and present the
info at scientific journals
and here's the thing as we bag on higher
ed and we continue to defund colleges
college is way too expensive that's a
whole other conversation but as we
continue to defund the public good
the drug companies come in and they pick
up the slack
right so if we have a the university of
texas or texas tech university
and or texas a m those are the three big
kids from where i'm from
rice university whatever
they hire their own scientists they do
their studies
they get grants from the federal
government from the state government
they use tuition dollars and they do a
study on something
and they put it out to the world and the
scientists bat it back and forth it's
called peer review they fight back and
forth over the results
and over time consensus comes to the top
and you have to put forth the the
studies that don't work you have to put
forth the studies that do work which
lead to new studies
when a pharmaceutical company runs those
things
they hire their own doctors they hire
their own doctor researchers medical
researchers
and then they do the studies and they
just need to
they need two to go right meaning they
can do a study
as johann hardy says in his book lost
connections which is an extraordinary
read
they can do a thousand studies 998 of
them
on a particular drug fail but two of
them
one of them with a population of 16 and
one of them a population of 100
and the population was 16 9 or 10 of
those
people for whatever reason showed some
trend towards positive this pill helped
them
and then in the study of 100
52 53 people got some help a little bit
of help here and there
or maybe a lot of help right
998 studies said this drug has no
effects
or it may even be hurtful to you you
just need two
and the fda will stamp it and say that
that drug is good to go to market
and so here's the deal there is none
zero evidence for the low serotonin myth
that your brain produces low serotonin
some people are just born that way
and taking pills will raise it and fix
you
as dr moncrief says there's no evidence
there's a chemical imbalance in
depressed or anxious people's brains
the dsm this manual it's they call the
psychiatric bible it's a real
thick book that's got all the diagnosis
right
you've got this you've got a that you've
got this
the manual that supposedly determines a
person's you know diagnosis
it's a mess it's a big mess and it
almost exclusively
never takes into environment context
being at a really controlled
in work environment in an abusive
relationship
from a traumatic childhood in a system
that's
traumatizing you those things don't
matter
it's all about this diagnosis in your
brain
here's the truth almost
entirely we don't know why medications
work
i'm talking about psychotropic
medications we don't know why they work
we simply don't know
there are a number of people who have
incredibly
positive results and they do well it
could be from placebo
that could be from actual support and
help
and here's the deal i am one of them
i got bent low by anxiety
to the point that i was spinning out all
over the place and i took anxiety
medications for a season
and they worked awesome when i'd asked
my doctor
why do these work he'd say i don't know
they were originally designed
for congestion and people were reporting
hey i'm feeling less anxious and so
they are a whole class of drugs that are
prescribed off-label off-brand
but they worked so here's the
broad picture of medication
for folks who are dealing with major
depressive disorders
schizophrenia bipolar
medication is magic it can be
extraordinary
particularly if you are doing it in
partnership with a great therapist with
good community groups with skilled
practitioners who know how to teach you
how to do relationships
and there are mental health issues again
like schizophrenia bipolar some of these
things that have brain lesions your
brain is actually different
okay there are others like myself
who took anxiety medication for a season
and it worked wonders
and i took it for a season for a
specific season and i
partnered with a doctor whose goal was
to teach me how to take ownership of my
own health
he didn't tell me and i had two doctors
one holistic doctor and one
medical doctor neither of them told me i
was broken forever
neither of them told me hey your brain
is just
dysfunctional and it's always going to
be that waste you need to take medicine
the analogy i got was hey you were
training for a marathon and you stepped
off the curb
and really messed up your ankle and just
so happens your ankle's in your head
the alarms got going for so long and you
were eating trash and not sleeping and
isolating yourself
for so long that your
alarms just took over right they just
took over
and so for a season we're gonna ask you
to not run don't run
you need to go to a doctor and get your
leg taken care of
and then you're going to have to go
through rehab physical therapy
and then you're going to start walking
and then you can start jogging and then
you can start training for whatever race
you want to run again
and it just so happened all that stuff
was in my mind so for a season i took
some medication don't know how it works
my doctor would tell me he was honest
dude i don't know why my holistic doctor
gave me some supplements and she she
actually knew more about what those were
doing than the
pharmaceutical
and we started with the lowest possible
dose first this was my arrangement with
my doctor you get your arrangement with
your doctor
i'm not giving you medical advice i'm
telling you it worked for me and then
we decided hey we'll move up later if we
need to we never did
and he worked with me on a plan to get
off and stay off and that meant i had to
go see a counselor
that mean i had to be really honest with
my wife
that mean i had to be really intentional
about getting friends and getting
connected in my local community
a person is not a person without their
environment
it's one of my favorite quotes from
hari's work a person is not a person
without their environment
medication can help a person's body turn
off the alarms shut down the yelling and
screaming and fear responses and trauma
responses and it did that for me
and it's done that for countless other
people but it is not
the long-term solution for most
everybody
and so just like we just did with kelly
she is brave
and she is strong and i'm so proud of
her
for having courage for being a great mom
being a great partner
and for recognizing i'm not doing well
but seriously seriously
the goal is not to be on medication
forever the goal is to
use meds as a bridge to get your life
back so kelly
thank you so much for your call for
being brave
no shame no failure
strength i'm proud of you for doing the
work that you need to do to get well
this is step one step two is going to be
boundaries relationships and connection
and finding ways you can control what
you can control in your little bitty
universe
i'm proud of you